whales are definitely more like humans
than we might think
they have quite an advanced culture they
have quite an advanced communication
methodology and we can learn a lot about
humans by looking at that culture whales
have their own dialects and they build
communities which are centered around
where they're from
so for whales community and
understanding that and being connected
to the community with which they were
born and lived their entire lives
together is so important for us being
able to know your identity and hold it
is so important as well
Wales will pass down information from
generation to generation through whale
song and similarly we as humans will
share information through our stories
often folk tales and nursery rhymes and
fairy stories the male's express
themselves through sound but the females
have a form of physical expression
through slapping their tails on the
surface of the ocean it's just another
way for them to communicate with
physically
so we know that one group of humpback
whales they'll be singing their song
that they all prefer their number-one
hits if you like and it will change very
slightly over time as they sing it to
each other as the male's sing during the
breeding season they're just very small
changes now there might be another group
say the other side of Australia and that
group singing an entirely different song
that's number one in their pop charts if
you like and what happens is
occasionally one or two of the whales
from the other side of Australia will be
hurt by the first bunch of whales and
something extraordinary occurs that song
that was number one for that first group
of whales it changes very quickly and
becomes exactly the same practically as
the song that was the number one hit for
the other bunch of whales on the other
side of Australia this is a
revolutionary song cage you can think of
it almost as as a total remix done by
one bunch of pairs on the other during
the summer months they actually stay in
the colder waters and they feed that's
their feeding grounds but then during
the winter they kind of go on holiday to
these warmer tropical waters and that's
their breeding grounds that's the
breeding season for humpback whales sort
of like a holiday with all the
seriousness of what we can learn from
these animals it's so important to
remember that actually the pure joy of
life is this wonderful added dimension
that we can't forget it's so important
to have fun
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon